Democratic Senator Elizabeth Warren of
Massachusetts has made her first visit
to Iowa as a likely presidential
candidate Warren announced this week
that she formed a presidential
exploratory committee her visit to Iowa
this weekend gives her a head start as
the first to begin organizing in a
democratic field that's expected to
include more than a dozen possible
candidates here to discuss the week's
events in Washington Iowa and everything
else is Gabe d Benedetti National
correspondent for New York Magazine Gabe
good morning morning let's start with
the shutdown is there any hint that this
impass could we could break it nope next
question to make a long story short the
two sides are uh talking about different
things here and neither side has a real
incentive to Cave uh we think that this
is going to end basically when the
president decides that he has the win
here when he says well there's a wall
now or I have funding for a wall but
because they're not actually talking
about the same thing the Democrats and
the president and what that would
actually look like we don't know when
that's going to happend but Gabe you and
I were talking before the show this
affects a lot of people and that means
there a lot of people right now not
getting paychecks so at what point does
it reach that moment of we now have to
actually come to that's a great question
and it does seem like Democrats have
said basically like on this one we're
actually not going to budge at all
because there's no in political
incentive for them to do so but there
will be more and more pressure on the
president particularly as more and more
things get shut down in the government
itself so we'll see but we think most of
the political pressure will be on his
end and it's going to be when he decides
he can declare Victory and so it could
be down to the of Democrats saying we
are not giving you a wall so it's not
listed in there you get your uh border
security funding and the president can
say look I can use that money for a wall
yeah ex something like that basically
the president has changed his wording a
few times when he's talking about the
wall offense steel slats security he
uses a bunch of different phrases here
so at some point a lot of people in
Washington think he will decide I will
say that what I've got here on the table
is a wall and that's good enough some
see that as a concession though moving I
mean some simply do yes absolutely and
there are a lot of people in the
president's base particularly
conservative commentators who have gone
after him in the past when he said
things like this so that's what he needs
to be wary of let's talk about the
Democrats we've seen a massive power
shift here at least in the house the big
question what is going on on the
impeachment front are they really going
to uh lay in well I think what you see
right now is Democrats trying to inch
around this conversation with the uh
with the words of uh congresswoman TB
that obviously became much more of a
national issue that Democrats were
prepared for but the Democrats in
leadership have basically said listen
we're going to take this slowly we're
going to lay lay the groundwork and this
is going to be a long process but some
of them quietly behind the scenes will
say you know it's not the worst thing in
the world to have some of our more
outspoken members out there talking
about this to rile up the base as long
as that's not the official party line as
we just saw Elizabeth Warren is already
in Iowa and every sort of political
season seems to start earlier and
earlier um this is as wide open as a
Democratic presidential election has
ever been isn't it yeah that's something
something like that you know jockeying
for this basically started the day after
the last election behind the scenes uh
but now it's finally bursting into the
open my current list of people who are
looking at running is well over 20
reaching 30 it's been longer than that
it's getting smaller as we get closer
but uh likely going to have upwards of
20 people announcing a lot probably in
the coming days and weeks as 2019 gets a
little bit older but Warren coming out
strong she's the first one with you know
the first big name potential candidate
to hit Iowa and a lot of people in the
Democratic party were watching very
closely last night you know one of the
other things that M mentioned in his
report that six-month extension for the
meller for the grand jury what might we
expect to see in the coming weeks in
this Mueller investigation especially
with the shift of power in the house now
as well yeah well you know the PE the
Democrats have basically said the
Democrats leading the house
investigations they've said let's let
Müller do what he's going to do we'll
hand him you know whatever we can
whatever information Republicans were
stopping from getting to him before but
we don't know of course what Muller is
going to do we never really know what
he's going to do and when but there have
been some indications that he's going to
start and start being a little bit more
active again now that we're in the new
year so maybe we'll start hearing a
little bit more about some reports
coming from him but maybe not all right
Gabe d Benedetti the no the best
answer no I
it it was Dave thank you thank you